drones for them or against them these
remotely controlled unmanned aerial
vehicles are the most controversial
gadgets to hit the skies whether they're
taking out military targets or just
delivering shopping items for Amazon
drones are making friends foes and
headlines everywhere I'm Dina and here's
this week in drone first up the United
States might be sending drones back to
Iraq is il militants are battling Iraqi
security forces for control of the
country leaving at least 1,000 dead and
even more fleeing for their lives Iraq
has repeatedly requested armed drones
from the US for months and the US
government has confirmed they received a
new request this week for drone strikes
against I fil on Thursday President
Obama put it like this we will be
prepared to take targeted and precise
military action if and when we
determined that the situation on the
ground requires it the US has used
drones over the past decade to target
alleged combatants in Yemen Somalia
Afghanistan and Pakistan but these
strikes often result in the death of
innocent civilians drones aren't just
used for war desert wolf a South African
drone firm just sold 25 of its new
drones that fire pepper spray bullets to
an undisclosed mining company in South
Africa for crowd control the skunk optic
copter loads up to 4,000 bullets firing
20 bullets every second all the while
using blinding lasers to tame crowds you
may recall the 2012 mining strikes in
South Africa when 22 miners died in
clashes with riot police so far this
year 70,000 miners have been on strike
for 21 weeks let's hope the skunk
octocopter isn't used anytime soon
remember when Amazon unveiled a
potential new way to deliver your stuff
via drone and everyone freaked out a
little well the monolithic online
retailer is doing more than ever to
change the laws in favor of commercial
drones this week amazon hired a major DC
firm to lobby for the proposed drone
program which would provide same-day
delivery for online purchases by 2015
Amazon CEO Jeff Bezos hopes to deliver
packages to customers via drones and as
little as 30 minutes and finally looks
like drones have also made their way to
the World Cup Frances manager believes
that a drone flying above his team's
training camp was spying on their final
preparations ahead of their Honduras
match last Sunday Pizza is looking into
the incident but judging from France is
3-0 victory that mystery drone wasn't
too effective so there you have it now
that you know a bit more about drones
tell us what you think and spread the
knowledge watch more videos by
subscribing to a j+
you